Here are the two solutions. Great work if you found both of those. First, we
split up each of these numbers into two factors. We want to make sure that one
of the factors is the largest square number that divides into it. For the first
one, we know the square root of 16 equals 4, and then we're left with
multiplying by the square root of 3y. We take the square root of 4 to you get 2
times the square root of 3y. And we take the square root of 9 to get 3 times
the square root of y. Be sure you keep the signs the same as you work. Now we
have like terms, since each one has a square root of 3y. We add 4 and 2, and
subtract 3 to get 3 times the square root of 3y. For the second problem, we
start by splitting up 8 into 4 times 2. And we split up 32 into 16 times 2. For
our numbers, we take the square root of 4 which equals 2. And this 2 stays
inside of our square root since it doesn't appear twice as a factor. For the
variables, we want to remember power divided by root. We take the power of 2
and divide it by 2 to get 1. This means x to the 1 appears outside of our
radical. For y, we'll do 3 divided by 2 because our index is a 2 here. We know
3 divided by an index of 2 equals 1 remainder 1. This means one y comes out,
and one y stays in. We saw this before when we're simplifying roots earlier. We
used power divided by root, and this number indicates the power outside of the
radical where the remainder indicates the power inside the radical. For our
second radical, we take the square root of 16, which equals 4. The 2 stays
inside of the square root and now we need to simplify y to the 3rd power. We
use power divided by root, so 3 divided by 2 equals 1 remainder 1. So, we have
one y on the outside and one y on the inside. We multiply the numbers together
infront of each radical to get 6xy times square root of 2y minus 8xy times the
square root of 2y. Now, we subtract these two radicals. We use 6xy minus 8xy to
get negative 2xy times the square root of 2y, our final result. Keep in mind
that there are two reasons why we could subtract here. We subtracted because
the radicals were alike and we subtracted because these polynomials were like
terms. We're really packing on the algebra now.